your eyes are a little watery I'm you
know what is going through my went good
I really am Garth Brooks congratulations
you are being honored by the Library of
Congress with the Gershwin Prize what
does this mean to you well you're
humbled it's like anything else when you
feel kind of excited embarrassed all
those things because there's so many
other you know writers that write
circles around you there are writers
that I am here because of those writers
and so it's week so as long as they all
know that very proud to accept this on
their behalf and just proud for the
songwriting community basically it's
just as a it's quite an honor and you're
also the youngest recipient that's got
to be great too when you look at you
know look at an award one do they have
to give it away every year and if that
answer is no and that award all of a
sudden elevates and then look at the
names that are on that award and all you
want to do manage you want to not bring
the award down by your name going on
with the rest of all it's what you want
to do so not only the what you went
through to get here but what you do in
the future
remember since that as well so I you
know you just proudly take it on you
hope you never embarrass them just
really really sweet that you're honoring
the seed to be here at the Library of
Congress what are you feeling have the
tears hit yeah it's pretty cool I mean
it's good cuz you know I'm not a smart
man but I'm married to a very smart
female and she's a she knows libraries
in and out of it and she's telling me
everything that's in everything and how
rare everything is so my thing is thank
God for the wisdom and the vision that
this country has seen to take care of
its arts and to take care of those
things that separate us from hopefully
animals and just uh just uh really
really proud to be in this all and to
get to be some little part of it well
there are some special items here at the
Library of Congress that we have pulled
out right here do you know what these
are right here you can pick them up I
can
you can okay this was hold the cow I
know this no telling by kollene Carol oh
so sweet huh : Carol is my mama mm-hmm
so she was a singer extraordinaire she
recorded Capitol Records in the mid 50's
and we kids are there were six of us a
blended family and we all agree 100%
that she kind of gave it up to raise us
so it's pretty cool so Betsy was the
only girl of the six kids
she was the blues guitarist fabulous
entertainer she was a bass player for us
so we all kind of got to live the dream
that mom didn't get to finish and we
kind of lived it for her so it's pretty
cool to hold to hold your mother's
copyrighted music in your hand that's
pretty cool that it's an ensuite and to
know that she was I don't know what is
she probably 18 21 she's doing this and
you think that's how old you were when
you started as well and mom was a
dreamer dad was the realist kind of
thing so while Dad was telling me you're
gonna go to college you're gonna get a
job my mom was always saying he just
keeps that music thing in your heart and
so it was sweet it was a perfect balance
I missed them both very much but I'm a
mama's boy so seeing my mom's
handwriting is very sweet what would
your mom say to you with this
recognition
oh let me give me a line everybody loved
whoo anytime mom they'd yell at mom from
the stands or something she'd say they
go I bet you're proud of here child
aren't you mom and always say which one
do you feel her presence especially
having her music right here in front of
you 24/7
my mom was very much like you you were
might be a little taller than her but
she was really just a fireball just
batteries going all the time and even
though she was tiny she would fight the
biggest person in the room for what was
right and so she lives with you every
day the hardest part was losing her but
then what I try and tell people is as
the time passes you realize oh my god
they're with you all the time now so she
is sitting right beside me as me and
you're talking yeah and dad's on the
other side still wondering if I'm going
to get a real job your eyes are a little
watery I don't know what
doing good I really am I'm doing good I
don't know you just you look at this and
you again it's all those things you feel
and you think of all the great
songwriters that you've known and all
the great songwriters that you pull from
James Taylor should be sitting in this
seat Bobby Braddock should be sitting in
the seat it's just it's really really
sweet to be getting sitting in the seat
and feeling like you are representing
songwriters because that's what yeah
that's what he came to town to be with a
songwriter you have pretty much received
every award possible that you can as an
artist and coming up I mean you are
receiving the icon award at the
Billboard Music Awards to be called an
icon do you see yourself as that no but
I remember I am a representative for the
country music audience okay so country
music radio country music audience the
country music fan it's the biggest most
loyal largest audience out there so it
only makes sense I'm happy that country
music now has a flag in the race there's
Elvis
there's Beatles and oh there's country
music that makes you proud so at the
billboards you go in there and again you
talk about the list of names Stevie
Wonder you know these guys now the
country flag gets to go up and and good
for country music it deserves it and I'm
the lucky guy that kind of gets to carry
the flag right now well speaking of
country music we have to give you a huge
congratulations as well on your ACM
nomination for music event of the year
with Blake Shelton for dive bar with
Blake Shelton what has that song meant
to you
no it's just it's just meant fun to me
and it's also kind of brought you know
there's a line in a song called all day
long that's on the same record and it
says somebody's got to play that country
that ain't ever coming back and for
three minutes on current radio here
Blake Shelton and Garth Brooks and
you're hearing that country music the
way it sounded
you know and also the way it sounded
from our heroes I mean his big hero you
know was George Strait everybody's is
and then straights big here was Haggard
which is everybody so I love hearing
traces of those guys and that's purely
egotistical that I just said that even
but I love hearing traces of their music
on current radio today makes me makes me
love country music you and more the
amount of success that you had with
Blake Shelton on that song who is the
next collaborator I don't know I love
singing with Trisha Yearwood I'm just
telling she kills me there's also a
photo here from back in 92 a throwback
of you and miss Yearwood right there
what kind of memories come to mind when
you see that photo it's all good
memories and it's all about timing is
what it is so if me and me said I fell
in love with Miss sure with the day I
met her I'd been married 13 months at
the time but we continued to be just
really good friends and really kind of
artists soul mates we could call each
other in the middle of the worst thing
going on in you know either one of ours
careers and kind of lean on each other
since so timing so I ended up me and the
girls mom ended up not working out
Trisha was single at the time and we
started dating for five years we dated
to try and ease those girls which she
had been bottle-feeding forever because
we have toured since 92 together since
first one was born so they knew her but
now they know her as mama T and it's um
I think things work out for a reason
because if we would have got married
then when I wouldn't have the three
daughters that I have which is my pride
and joy but uh - I really don't think
our careers would have been with the
work or our marriage wouldn't have
survived the 90s because the 90s was the
nineties was a hell of a ride for
everyone in country music probably not
saying it was the greatest decade for
country music but by far it was the most
successful decade for country music and
that that wave was a pretty pretty wild
ride well you can tell some news from
this photo with those acid-washed jeans
yes the rain go to brush popper that I'm
wearing you bet you in it's a I think
it's still one of the only intends the
the Takamine so that's it's you see the
lasers it's funny how western wear like
anything else has its you know has it's
bad I do love that you keep referring to
a lot of things as fun yes is that one
of the reasons why you've named your
upcoming album fun yes it was like a
what's the I'm like well it's
fun it's stupid there's a song called
party girl on there and I'm not even
sure you can get away with the lyrics
actually it's so much funny when it
comes on and just start started and then
there's a song called it's a hard way to
make a need to live and it's for
everybody who's ever played any die part
on the planet and so with things like
that mm-hmm
that's why it's fun I know the time
frame is always such a tricky question I
mean your fans are eagerly awaiting this
album do we have an update turn it in
February 29th on leap year turned it in
done yeah so we're hoping to open this
summer early summer well we know that
you are booked and busy you just started
the second year of your three-year North
American Stadium tours man what do we
have to do to get lizzo on stage with
you during this stadium tour and of
course trishal yearly lizzo is too cool
for me first of all I couldn't carry her
shoelaces my wife she's her biggest fan
so my wife were just here at the Ryman
in Nashville now the Ryman is the holy
place right and my wife got tickets
through a friend at an agent and she
walked in she was late and she felt bad
and she really felt bad when they walked
her right down to the front row and she
goes cars my hand was on the stage she
took so many pictures she was a fan and
so I said so I looked I said so how you
doing she goes she told us that she
wants an inflatable but it's been a
pleasure it's so much come gradually
thank you very much you're so excited
thank you for taking the time to chat
with us